now it's possible you haven't noticed
all the wicked ways these snowflakes and
soy boys are sabotaging Halloween so
I've invited some of our citizen
journalists to share some scary stories
submitted for the approval of the 30
minutes to midnight society our first
tale tonight comes from Aaron and Josh
who are dressed as Don jr. and Eric
Trump we're sexy Don jr. and Eric
[Applause]
you're gonna be so aroused Mike Pence is
gonna send you to conversion therapy our
story is called the tail of the
brainwashed school Halloween is now
considered - and I'm quoting
non-inclusive to be celebrated in at
least two elementary schools in
Massachusetts Boyden elementary school
will be replacing happy with black and
orange spirit Anthony this is insane
doing it because it's not inclusive of
all students there is no more inclusive
holiday than Halloween everyone gets to
participate malla ween yes
Jordan everyone is allowed to
trick-or-treat except for some religious
kids and diabetic kids and childless
drunk adults apparently thanks for the
ankle bracelets stay tuned New York
honestly you wear it well thank you but
Jordan that's the problem with
inclusivity the PC police are so scared
of leaving one person out now no one
gets Halloween during school hours once
they go home that everyone gets
Halloween but still it's spooky
[Music]
terrifying stuff terrifying the last
time I was that frightened I trusted
nate silver as a legitimate polling
source the coal you look positively
horrifying now everyone thinks halloween
is about looking fabulous just listen
halloween now becoming more politically
correct as college campuses try and
dictate what students can and cannot
dress up as Wesleyan University putting
up these posters asking if your costume
is offensive is it ok for people to
dress up like an American Indian I
thought multiculturalism was a good
thing Kevin liberal dress up as Barack
Obama if your wife I don't even want to
go there ok like Jedi or ninja or Latino
I know all these colleges might be
putting up posters that say Nicole you
don't understand the history behind what
you are wearing you are treating
someone's heritage as a joke and to that
I say this is not a joke I am seriously
killing this kimono what better way to
respect the culture than by walking a
mile in someone else's shoes and getting
blackout drunk in a skin tone
that's for showing respect oh yes the
sensitivity from the left is more
frightening than when I found my exes
NPR tote bag looking under my bed but I
want to really get chill so let's see
what Kobe has for us
hello Jordan I'm obviously the DMC
receipt for the Clinton Russia dossier
and the scariest thing about my costume
is how little the mainstream media is
covering it Kobe I don't know if I can
take another story about whiny liberals
getting all triggered at a fun made-up
holiday about goofs and pranks they're
so sensitive
either way to Sin City to relax it's
just a holiday and here if you've got
another story of some super sensitive
liberals who are freaking out over some
itty-bitty Halloween thing actually this
one is about anti-trump long decorations
how dare they are nala ween let me set
the scene a Halloween display in New
York sparking outrage it says deep rump
burn in hell is what is written on a to
stone we'll never know which D Trump
this tombstone refers to but Jordan I
think it might be Donald comfy I don't
like this one I don't like this one at
all
first of all it's wrong D Trump is not
going to hell he's going to heaven
minimum that's not even the worst part
Jordan that tombstone is pitting
neighbor against neighbor tweeter
against tweeter fighting about politics
on Halloween as if it were Thanksgiving
or any day on Facebook okay Kobe what
are you saying
this is one big liberal ploy to ruin yet
another holiday pretty soon we'll be
saying happy October 31st instead of
merry Halloween
[Music]